thanks to my patrons for making this
video possible
from the people who brought you humans
really are changing the climate and yes
the climate really is changing like
right now not in 50 years already now
comes a bunch of stuff we already knew
this week the intergovernmental panel on
climate change released the sixth
assessment report from working group
three completing the triforce of
documents detailing climate change and
finally giving antonio guterres the
forces of power wisdom and courage to
defeat wait no that's not right the two
recent reports from the ipcc detailed
what we know about how humans are
changing the climate and what effect
this is having on the planet
respectively this report details how
humanity can mitigate or prevent the
effects of climate change and
specifically reduce the rate that we
emit greenhouse gases of course
unfortunately most of modern society
from growing food to transport to
generating electricity currently
involves emitting greenhouse gases
taking carbon from the earth's crust and
putting it into the atmosphere by
burning fuels that's fundamentally
what's put us into this situation but
that also means that the climate change
problem is one that's quite simple to
solve to quote my phd supervisor just
keep the carbon in the ground
that's all we need to do and this report
has some very encouraging news on that
front we are making progress average
energy intensity has decreased meaning
that for every kilowatt hour of energy
used by humans fewer greenhouse gases
are now being emitted though there are
now more humans and we are using more
energy per person though definitely not
evenly that means that total emissions
have increased
but the rate of increase of global
emissions has fallen over the past
couple of years and that's not because
of the pandemic but because we now have
technology that is low carbon and cost
effective in particular the report
highlights the plummeting cost of
electricity generation through solar and
wind and the use of electric vehicles
for land-based transport and it also
highlights that climate policy works
governmental policies designed to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions have worked to
date and have worked particularly
effectively when synergized with
sub-national policies across multiple
sectors but i was surprised in reading
this report by something that could be
described as a rotten core to it
carbon capture gretchen stop trying to
make carbon capture happen it's not
going to happen it's generally accepted
that there are some sources of
greenhouse gas emissions that are simply
unavoidable such as for example creating
concrete or using fertilizers on farms
and to counteract this various
technologies have been proposed that
would suck carbon out of the atmosphere
and drag it back down into the earth's
crust into deep storage resulting in net
zero emissions from these activities
entirely sensible however the report
dedicates a fair bit of time to
discussing these technologies and even
goes so far as to suggest that they
could be used on mass to counteract the
burning of fossil fuels allowing for
fossil fuels to be burned for longer
and reading that sentence was for me a
bit like that moment in the shawshank
redemption where the pebble goes through
the poster of raquel welch
everything just rang a little bit hollow
because there is simply no way we can
carbon capture our way out of being
fossil fuel dependent its potential
impact is way too small and it is way
too expensive and to convince yourself
otherwise requires
pipe dream technology the only way that
we will prevent catastrophic climate
change is to stop emitting greenhouse
gases into the atmosphere which means
stopping the use of fossil fuels
within the next few
years so then why is carbon capture so
prominently featured in this report
well the corporations that control the
extraction and use of fossil fuels are
some of the most powerful in all of
human history and of course they will
resist anything that threatens their
existence cross-reference exxon
knowingly burying evidence of man-made
climate change in particular fossil fuel
companies lobby governments to not enact
policies that would effectively wipe
them off the books
something that to date
has been rather effective how effective
well as this report says
we are currently not going to limit
global warming to one and a half degrees
celsius by the year 2100 the target that
the paris agreement set in fact with
current government policies we're
looking at more like
3.2 degrees of warming by 2100 even if
all pledges made at cop26 were perfectly
upheld and turned into policy
we're looking at maybe
1.8 degrees of warming in other words
this report says that government leaders
who claim that climate change is a top
priority and that they are taking the
action necessary to avoid disaster
are lying
their actions just don't match up with
their words on a national or on an
international level and to a greater
lesser extent that policy landscape has
been determined by fossil fuel lobbying
so to recap the report says that we are
not even close to limiting global
warming to safe levels and that to do so
would require the use of this technology
and all these policies to remove fossil
fuels from the energy mix
or
you could suck carbon out of the air and
carry on a bit like before burning
fossil fuels it's not going to happen to
even put that on the table to even
consider an alternative to rapidly
phasing out the use of fossil fuels in
the energy mix is
in my opinion
conceding defeat and more than that
conceding defeat to a pipe dream we must
emphatically reject the notion in this
report in a part of this report that
carbon capture can somehow cancel out
the burning of fossil fuels at least in
the present and the near future
late century negative emissions sure
almost certainly necessary but to
believe that that's an option in the
present
obfuscates meaningful action and yes
this report emphasizes for the first
time individual actions and i'd argue
there's some level of moral
responsibility to changing your behavior
as an individual but while being vegan
and not flying and driving an electric
car will make a difference
it's not how we're going to solve this
problem
government policy is how we're going to
solve this problem the report makes it
clear that policy works especially when
it involves diverse actors and across
multiple domains it just needs to be
ambitious enough and crucially not
controlled by the lobbying of fossil
fuel companies so if your country's
leader is not taking this issue
seriously if their actions don't match
up to their words and if their policies
don't fundamentally remove our
dependence on fossil fuel infrastructure
hold them to account demand that they
change their policies and if they won't
don't vote for them vote for the party
that actually promises meaningful change
this report showcases that we have the
technology we have the know-how to fix
this problem
but it also bizarrely gives powerful
fossil fuel polluters an out with this
discussion of carbon capture
it just makes the whole thing ring
hollow especially knowing that
it wouldn't work but make no mistake the
trio of reports we've seen recently are
unequivocal
we are causing the climate to change
we are already feeling the effects of
this
and we have the means to stop it and to
stop burning fossil fuels
and we need to do that
fast in this video i focused on the
surprising emphasis of this report on
carbon capture but to be clear there is
a ton of material in here that is
focused on more meaningful change and
what we should be doing to get more of
an overview of that check out my friends
miriam and adam who have made a video or
alternatively if you prefer physical
media check out drawdown a book about
how we can remove our dependency on
fossil fuels with tons of data both of
those are linked in the description
thank you very much for watching this
one all the way to the end here's a link
to adam and miriam's video and also to
my video on the most recent ipcc report
from working group 2. if you did take
something from this please do share it
with other people that you think may
find it interesting and you can also pop
it a like and if you really want to
support me you can also support me over
on patreon also linked on the screen
thank you again for watching and i'll
see you in the next one